hi guys I'm back playing Fran go again
for you this time let's actually have a
look through the world because we met
Falkor last time wasn't really foul cool
but it's pretty much fell cool and now
I'm actually gonna walk around and see
wait weird tree we were tree let's just
have fun being a tree he okay yeah so
she said that we couldn't go up there
because partly unknown something about
times or something I saw look at you
told me that we have to find Mountain
pot room and the great wizard ok that's
what we were told apparently it's let's
go do that are we getting it picked up
by a flying boat this is very scary but
it's a beautiful it is very pretty it's
so weird cuz this game was really
terrifying for a while and now it's like
the opposite so pretty yeah I can't read
that oh well I don't understand now
another do I it's the tree symbol but I
wonder what it says hmm hello sir I'm
not away I thought he was calling her
sister um but it was actually Fran
calling him I said are you a guard yes
obviously uh-oh is he do you know where
the mountain khatron is yes well are you
gonna tell us can you tell me where it
is please yes okay go on then well tell
me please the mountain bottom is only in
wintertime wintertime what are you
talking about of course wintertime what
do you think but i can't wait for winter
oh you don't want to wait wait you don't
wait for it you go there oh I go to
winter time bar is this like another lat
how do I go but how ah sorry i'm not
good at explaining things go downstairs
and then straight ok well wintertime
isn't very far away why don't we just go
you'll find a clockmaker he can explain
things
oh okay it's the way towards the cops
make it right I got it all right thank
you sir what is that noise let's go take
the stairs it's a look at math okay so
we came from here and now we're like
here or something that's the ground very
well done friend that's the ground a
mountain okay so I'm guessing that's why
we need to go so I think we take it down
here a very big tree right yeah let's do
that let's go this way I know you told
us to go straight but we're rule
breakers here on ya granik's we're
really not let's destroy it see how this
artistry school it's like a steampunk
tree this is very odd clock what are the
numbers that vs it has symbols and
colors but it doesn't seem to show the
time oh it sounds like something broke
Oh does the journal tell us anything
like we met this feels like becoming
what you can understand on earth it's
why leave sing while falling off the
tree and the water whispers its wisdom
while you drink it that's refused oh
here we go so are these the letters on
the top lock you reckon those letters
they sound funny yeah they are they
totally are I think I don't know ok
let's go this way cricket hello good
daily everything for each are all good
ah I feel a lot I don't know I feel a
lot of things lately Oh feelings they're
beautiful just like this flower hmm okay
what are you doing are you waiting for
somebody are you gonna get that flower
to someone like your mom I'm waiting for
lemons to grow you like lemons yeah I
like lemons and was a hot hot water and
lemon is nice then it's our for my taste
but lemonade's Jimmy emanate it's what i
will do with lemons so the customers of
the bar you know what bar i wanna go to
the bar and we put some other stuff in
it too so we can fly red bowl that
sounds great i'd like to try that yes
that is why i wait you can't rush it
okay thus far opens in full and so I
awesome a very awesome dance and will
perform you should come hang out I will
sounds fun does can we be the dancer
where are the lemon thing can we get
them I recognize this kind of tree and
grace have one at home it's a it's a
lemon tree I think but I don't think
lemon trees had little flowers on them
whatever let's go
this way here we go use these numbers
huh it must say something important
let's have a look let's translate I'm
not going to be able to remember what
that says okay so i can remember this
one this one i wish i could move it over
and then have a look what is that one me
I score I can't bothered with this you
guys can work it out if you want to you
can tell me what it says I'd be very
grateful well I wonder what this is no
idea looks like a tropical party place
Frizzle brought it up wait mr. midnight
they'll go wandering off everyone lose
you again okay here we go we're going at
the mountain let's go this week's as
it's pretty nothing here but trees and
flowers oh ok made it to the mountain
peak do you think it's a person it's
gonna start speaking to us I wonder what
a talking mountain would sound like yeah
that's exactly what I'm thinking it's
what some very loud like an earthquake
oh ok it's not going to start talking to
us as that fine fine let's go back the
way we were told
trying to cut corners can't do that
what's this way well this is weird what
the hell oh wow what are you you don't
like the fairies in my books have you
not realized there's a lot of weird
things like things you book the fewest
awake mm-hmm the purest of feelings the
light of all materials we are the
lockers hmm oh you're very shiny and you
made me feel so happy so very happy
really I think they make me feel they're
an easy to be honest look creature one
of the young Vallecas will receive the
shield unlike my female role on what my
age what the hell turn those voices the
way oh oh he got his she on his head
soldier of the Sun preacher from the
soil fruit from seed let the universe
illuminate you with the truth and be
free huh where are you all going we
continue our paths to life may freedom
be with you my friend like Jedi sir or
miss hmm can you do magical face the
universe is already doing magic all the
time you are full of magic yourself but
I wish to know things and it's odd I
feel like you know everything we are the
light we are everywhere what answers are
you looking for I want to know who
killed my parents and why that big
monster is hunting me the truth will
calmly to those who seek your path
towards truth is immense you are living
in a world that times it back to you you
are too fragile to face the truth just
now and too strong to let it go
well that didn't answer any of my
questions like but it didn't answer
anything did you'll be sad we have to
keep on going listen to mr. midnight yes
kitty you're right oh yeah no they don't
know anything they just know how to talk
the talk but they can't walk the walk
well what a huge buckets it's not real
though yeah what what are we trying to
do here I have no bloody clue right
let's just go where we were supposed to
go I'm sure we will understand maybe
soon ish oh cool you told me we have to
find mount smelting bottom and the great
wizard wait us miss a midnight space no
I'm trying to talk to turn it man what
whatever hello it was there who I try to
doing different voices like all right uh
me friend can't you see me oh now I see
I see a little you have four eyes Wow um
four words I don't have what is selling
I wanted to ask problem something at
Ireland do you want to smell it uh sure
but they look like coconuts
it's pumas who is it I collect their not
coconut who I know what your poop who
like in the toilet wow I thought it's
really fancy to add white very yummy we
love it here it makes everything throw
and shine that's true it's a good
fertilizer I have to get going now good
luck with the plumbers by weird weird
things good thread and cloth to make
stuff it's very good I'm trying to talk
to ratings are you interested in fabric
and thread I have some uh why out of
curiosity miss the whole purpose do you
use a fabric everybody's naked well
whatever you need it for we also have
thread for making other things i see
hmmm i have to go miss haven't I say bye
she's like hmm let's talk to this is a
bouncing no I can I just walked through
him okay all right let's also go is
first we talking to you hello I'm fan
what are you doing good day I'm puja and
I'm molding this piece of iron Oh for
what
I have to deliver a clock a few clock
pieces to the clockmaker that's what I'm
going I think oh I see do you do you can
so you can do all kind of metallic stuff
sure if I have some ideas we can talk
about them and a damn I'll do it but um
that's very good to know thank you sir
well I have to keep working if you need
my services you know where I am a damn
okay let's go I feel weird not taking
the pills and seeing creepy things ah so
cute ah that's look cute I want a sort
of the caterpillar hello miss I think
you have beautiful fruits thank you dear
as you like them oh no I'm on a mission
to go back home and I want to be hung I
don't want to be hungry no she wants to
be hungry when she gets there oh so from
what part of Earth sister are you are
you from outside the land no I'm not
from a stir at all I'm a human Oh human
that's new well I hope you complete your
mission thank you Miss I certainly will
see ya here's the clockmaker hello what
are you doing mm-hmm working on my clock
Oh see Sergey know where i can find the
great wizard no miss I do clocks I fixed
Glocks I listened our clocks tick tock
hmm do you know whether mountain and pot
Ramez the only mountain costume only
exists in wintertime otherwise it's just
a regular Mountain oh so we'll talk to
us but only in wintertime I can't wait
for winter the king said the wizard will
be in Mountain courtroom you don't need
to wait for winter to come that's absurd
time is an infinitely layered reality
will we get deep now we can deep ah i
layered reality that sounds great what
do i do go to the clock and change
season just change it oh okay so where's
the clock it's the one that we already
found go towards the castle then take
your left hand while you see the stairs
yes where we went before you find a big
clock on the tree good luck I already
saw that poconos broken a broken clock
that's a disgrace poor clock you have to
help me please fix it for me I beg you I
have to go home I never fix a [ __ ] for
nothing otherwise my lifetime goes to
waste come on you gotta do some stuff
for free especially if you enjoy doing
it what do you mean I charge one big
golden coin per clock time is gold you
know hmm I don't have any coins hmm then
o clock will ever be fixed mm-hmm can
you just do it as a favor I need to go
home I can't have you then from we won
going coin or nothing will be fixed fine
thank you i'll see if i can get some
gold for you where am I gonna get is
there anyone here that I can work for
for a day or an hour hello ladies don't
I news good day would you like to read
the newspaper um I can't read a sister
hmm what is the essences language cord
but you know what's it's called s a
third ish are you a tourist yes I am a
Taurus my name is Fran I've never seen
it tourists before and I've never seen a
friend either welcome to earth astir I
hope you all have fun here thank you so
much I have to go okay that was
pointless conversation unless it's to
carry heavy things I want you to sit on
it Oh get mr. midnight so jumper one ND
your world oh no we mustn't sleazy
little miss admit I actually
all right let's go mmm hello little
fruit you are so cute oh thank you
you're cute you'll see i'm fran and you
mean oh I'm not far i'm jealous and I
went to sing all day long oh I love
singing too what's your favorite song my
favorite song goes like this she gonna
start singing this is gonna be weird
today mom and what add two and two or
three students they are five and five
eight and I don't remember any more of
that that's a terrible terrible song I
learned that at school it's bad that
sounds very mathematical I have to go
now you have vertical foots by the way
see such strange conversations front how
to these people hello good day young one
what are you doing war is about to start
and I can't see the meaning in
meaningless uh-huh what do you mean join
me young one yo B we're all in with a
golden coin if you come back alive join
you join you where the game is about to
begin you are the Kamala's I am able
opus
like and white our shadows and light
this is chess or something or checkers
this is a board game sir yes a board
game that's a mass in this adventure you
against me I give you a gold coin if you
winning what do you say yeah yeah yeahs
course sure what are the rules first to
play three of the same fingers in a
diagonal horizontal or vertical line
wins we can do this think I'll played a
similar game when I play down
machinarium what's the name ok cool sure
sounds like a game we used to play at
school called tic-tac-toe but why would
you just give me the gold if I win time
is gold and I'm Larry old I've been
around a long time I just want to have a
good time I see well let's play ok so
I'm black
okay so he's for his then let's do this
I'm gonna put mine here and be annoying
first up where one might doing why is it
I do that I'm an idiot okay um that's on
it yeah hey I one doesn't like oh
darling I totally won that was so easy I
got my coat coin I don't need another
one I'll screw it let's play another
game no one wins oh well whatever I got
my gold coin I'm happy they will then
little creature you are a master I am a
master it's sorts of this cool cool what
is he he's at reasoning good day sir
good day little creature I imagine him
being like winded console Eva I can't do
the voice I've seen flying boats there
how does that work think of them
floating on water but instead of
floating its air it's so simple can I
borrow any your boats to fly away I want
to go home Oh go alone I see sadly these
phones only where I cannot stand slave
then hmm I see well thank you have fun
making a boat cool let's go get that guy
I'll go coin so we'll use the gold coin
use that with this guy here sir your
gold coin what's that I haven't fixed
any of your clocks oh but I thought you
wanted a coin to fix the glog oh yes for
you have to offer me the dog first all
right do it and be polite okay Oh sir
clockmaker would you like to fix my
clock it's not even her glove in
exchange for this piece of gold and in
the name of
a time I beg you x no I beg you accepts
my offer of course that was an
incredible job offer very passionate hey
let's go into the big clock and fix it
yeah he's like a spider Oh creepy no my
gate had a spider fall on me the other
day I opened up the window and it fell
down and it's one of those disgusting
fake black widows that we have in
England but hook it's Christ you can fix
it right of course just a second oh my
what hmm yes no there what is it seems
that somebody was playing a dirty game
around this log who what do you mean I
leave somebody broke it it's in love
making a defenseless [ __ ] oh why would
somebody break hit their mls winter
hunting got your list owns many reels
and business what are you talking about
I don't understand Camelot's the evil
darkness they work for a more the
terrible work and camel are the only
ones allowed a rule in this land the
only evil we have around it wouldn't
surprise me the more once the stones but
what I don't understand this or what
purpose there stands and meaningless for
him and it seemed him and the stones are
in wintertime it's for more a giant
black monster with a goat mask a a dead
goat mask yes you know
yeah I think it's because of him I'm in
this land I'm a human you know Oh a
human now I understand i also need the
stones they're my only way back home I
hope it's not too late a hat this is why
you need to go into winter time and go
to Mountain coat room well yes you very
hard far behind on this exactly own to
talk to the great visit and borrow the
stones hmm but it sticks now I'll give
you something that will make it easy for
you here thanks missing blue is
wintertime it's a remote control look
hot that's very good because we don't
understand the language you'll be able
to travel in all four seasons in just a
quick 10 it's just a prototype so it may
not work if you're too far away and then
I'm birth time is an infinite layered
reality so be careful I'll be careful
thank you very much you're very nice
clock make you guys please call me cold
wind no Pope whines I get it all right
mystical grind i'm fran by the way see
you soon I ok let's do this
ah cool okay so we need to go to winter
time so let's do that I love how the gem
changes color okay wintertime do this
wintertime is kind of creepy I like it
and let's go 300 of course the lemons
and the party let's go to a party hey
okay see ya let's see if the lemons
already ya hear the lemons they're ready
so how can I take one of your lemon I'm
sorry lovey the lemons I can't remember
if the voices for everyone I did the
lemons resources are quite limited I
can't now you take them I take all the
lemon them in the basket and carry that
means all the time until the tree okay
so will he yeah this is the pie screw in
a time let's go to apply I'm so excited
I don't get invited I Jake it and write
it I can go to this party good three
different movies can you please show me
your ticket Oh like I invited other side
I have a ticket how do I get one what
all of the citizens got a ticket why do
you have yours uh I'm not a citizen sir
maybe that's why not a citizen that's
new too new for me though sorry little
lady I can't let you in alright so I
understand now what do i do then i
really like to get inside I don't know
this has never happened before hmm i
guess i'll have to find my own way to
get inside Thanks I
I'm gonna gain the party this sucks give
me the party you just make this thing
down to us instead anyway ok can I go in
the party now no hey the shows about to
begin you waited a whole season for that
winter time it is always totally gone
the party is totally gone packed up and
gone away wow it's a cave you know cool
it's the wizard always at hey oh I hear
the great wizard sir Dada um are you
because if you are them we need dog
excuse me can you talk you have too many
questions that's good ok oh sorry sir
the king told me you could help me what
the King says we do um ok mm-hmm I need
you to let me the stones to open the
door to my world the stones are missing
and I I don't remember where they are
every time they seek I hide every time I
hide I forget so they can't be found you
you make no sense for a great wizard
you're not making any sense right now
they you mean the black shadows sir I
just want to know the biggest answer of
the morn how does the rapid do it what I
saw it once a human did it the rabbit
came from an empty hat oh okay he's
baffled by a magician how the crisis
question of them all because if nothing
exists then the nothing exists this is
heavily influenced by never ending story
is gonna be the nothing come on than
nothing if you haven't seen it you need
to watch that film but if the nothing is
this and there is no nothing I wonder
again how hmm I know how he could ask me
I know how they do the trick oh I I have
a visitor good day what brings you to
the correct wizard well he's only just
notice I'm here that means me just so
you know okay good day sir it king sent
me here for the stones in the stones ah
it's been a long time since somebody
came asking for those i made the most
fantastic spell of all times and nobody
could find them well that's not good you
know the black shadows the Kamala's they
try to seal them all the time so i have
to be sure
the king told me the stones would open a
door to go home the stones are hiding I
only remember the four riddles that are
connected to the students for videos up
an unlocked my memory only when all four
riddles are answered correctly I will
then be able to tell you where to find
five items these items are the stones
and then layered reality then okay so
one stone for each viotti cool then the
only one who can bring them back is me
oh that's a lot of information let me
show you cool
this is the star of our sister Oh mark
up there the greatest guide of the sky
the greatest care they girl this land
hmm and what do I have to do so what are
the riddles I'll give you the four
whittles written down in the language of
everything the answer is always one item
place the items on the stir of our
sister on their respective symbol and
after that I'll be able to tell you
where the stones are oh that's got a
little like oh thank you very much sir
with it oh so is it the King tell me
that you can make me human again did he
hmm I think that's true I barely
remember how to do it though you're
you're certain annoying with wait you
don't remember I can't go home like a
tree I understand but I can't help you
right now I have to recover some of my
knowledge perhaps we can try to make you
human again after you find the first
stone oh that would be incredible yes
incredible and great just try to figure
out the riddles and I guess everything
will not be fine sad do I need something
special to become a human hmm i think
the smell is very important
if i remember correctly so bring me your
clothes and we'll see how it goes where
are my clothes because I got flown away
I gotta find this clothes okay tell me
the riddles oh right oh I see so the
riddles are more dislike pictures the
rabbit science is waiting it's a hidden
it's a hidden compartment it's a hidden
compartment hmm it's such as a cool
little picture okay I'm cold as I am but
if you use me I'll be burning hard hmm
I'm shiny as the Sun but I'll never burn
you perhaps a sour smile I'll get you
okay oh maybe like a gem a crystal a
crystal yeah definitely whistle Flo Flo
cold-blooded son let your body dance
through the rising stream that's
interesting lighten hollow I'm the
freedom of breads and the pen of men hmm
oh yeah a lot of that doesn't even make
any sense to me interesting let's go up
here I want to see if that mountain
talks to us yet Hey Oh what it's that
dragon or a bird what's draggin that is
cool Getty did you see that did you yes
my dear I saw it what was it huh I i
think there's the shadows oh dear I
don't want to see them again never did
like a cool dragon again yes kitty they
were all over the place in the hospital
I want to go home we will go home soon
my dear kitty can you make me a promise
that whatever happens you and I will
always be on the same side of course my
dear I promise great now we have to keep
on going hmm
i wanna i wanna see the dragon again
look at the dragon ah it wasn't it was
Oh Falkor I don't care what the name is
mr. Fellig or elantris sir it's her get
really bad kitty wasn't that the doctor
maybe he can cure himself I don't think
that's how r exit doctors are not a peek
they can't make themselves a pig does
that make sense I hope so kitty he was
so hurt that he lost a feather I wonder
what happened and you thought he was a
shadow present hmm I wonder if the
feather it's one of the items that we
need what do you think lighten hollow on
the freedom of birds and the pen of men
sweet that is one we've got one already
I think I'm gonna leave it there we met
the wizard we saw a Falkor in his dragon
form which is
awesome and next episode we're gonna go
see if he's okay and get the rest of
these items I'll see you give this a
thumbs up if you enjoyed and have a
lovely their evening
the cat's got you still don't have
opposable thumbs but you know he's still
going Oh take a proud of you know they
do have a possible oh I just found it I
want to count Cassel bad don't be afraid
friends